i'm shaking my head no on that one
sherry but
there you go uh nothing to shake your
head out with the freeways excellent
shape here as you're getting going
trying to get out the door here before 4
30. earlier crash looks like it is out
of the way and even then it wasn't a
huge deal north on the i-15 after the
spaghetti bowl so keep an eye on the
right hand side of the road as you're
coming up on washington street they were
taking up some space there might be an
emergency vehicle behind that sign there
freeway traffic never really affected so
we have a chance to look in on the old
big squeeze 95 515 just those two lanes
as you know between the spaghetti bowl
over towards charleston usually during
the four game hour it's not a huge deal
and that certainly is the case right now
here we have the headlights heading into
the downtown area
all this open real estate here is where
they're continuing to work on what's
called officially the i-515
rehabilitation project for you you just
need to know you only have those two
lanes there john